und ich sage guten Abend nach Washington
Gudrun Engel schauen wir doch ein
bisschen näher auf das was da im Moment
gerade vorgeht Donald Trump sagt das ist
ein politischer Prozess was sagen denn
die Amerikaner und Amerikanerinnen dazu
ja tatsächlich hat eine aktuelle Umfrage
ergeben dass es auch da darauf ankommt
welche Amerikaner man fragt fragt man
Amerikaner die sich eher dem
republikanischen Lager zuschreiben dann
sagen 62 %. ja wir finden auch das ist
politisch motiviert fragt man auf der
anderen Seite die Amerikanerinnen und
Amerikaner die er demokratisch wählen da
sagen 32% nein nein dieses Verfahren ist
auf jeden Fall ganz klar juristisch
motiviert und es geht um Recht und
Gesetz das ist also sehr gemischt und
bei den Partei Anhängern da ist es eben
ganz klar die Republikaner sagen das ist
eine politische Hetzjagd und sie
begründen ist eben damit dass der
Staatsanwalt der die Anklage verfasst
hat zu den Demokraten gehört dazu muss
man halt wissen Staatsanwalt ist in den
Vereinigten Staaten ein politisches Amt
das heißt es der Staatsanwalt wird vom
Volk gewählt er ist also zwangsläufig
immer entweder bei den Demokraten oder
bei den Republikanern in der Partei
zuständig und deswegen ist jetzt eben
dieser Angriff das heißt der
demokratische Staats halt verfolgt
politische Ziele und hat deswegen den
ehemaligen republikanischen Präsidenten
Donald Trump angeklagt und auch deswegen
oder das mag vielleicht auch ein Grund
sein warum hier auf der anderen Seite
des großen Teiches bisher nur Stimmen
aus der republikalischen Partei
angekommen sind die sich hinter Donald
Trump stellen oder gibt es andere
nein das ist in der Tat so ganz viele
Republikaner haben sich jetzt hinter
Donald Trump versammelt auch die die in
den vergangenen Wochen und Monaten so
ein bisschen von ihm abgerückt sind und
sogar die die eigentlich in dem nächsten
Präsidentschaftswahlkampf gegen ihn
antreten wollen als republikanischer
Kandidat beispielsweise sein ehemaliger
Vizepräsident Pants oder auch der
Gouverneur von Florida de Santis sie
alle versammeln sich jetzt und halten
die rein der Republikaner quasi
geschlossen von den Demokraten gibt es
nur vereinzelt Stimme nennt sie pillow
sie die ehemalige Sprecherin des
Repräsentantenhauses hat sich zu Wort
gemeldet und hat gesagt es ist ganz
wichtig dass Recht und Gesetz über allem
steht und dass jeder Amerikaner und
jeder Amerikanerin vor dem recht gleich
ist und dass auch jeder gleich verfolgt
wird das ist aber er eben so eine Ansage
Anrecht und Gesetz dass sie alle gleich
behandelt werden sollen und eben um
Druck rauszunehmen aus der politischen
Debatte alle gleich behalten werden das
ist ein gutes Stichwort zum Verfahren
wie geht das denn jetzt weiter mit
Donald Trump wie jeder
gemeindeverbrecher behandelt werden
tatsächlich scheint das so zu sein also
es ist jetzt vereinbart worden dass er
am kommenden Dienstag nach New York
reist etwa 14 Uhr amerikanischer Zeit
also 20 Uhr deutscher Zeit soll er dann
da sich bei Gericht einfinden und dann
sollen hinter verschlossenen Türen eben
zum einen erst die Fingerabdrücke
genommen werden und dann so diese
klassischen Fotos die wir aus den
Vereinigten Staaten kennen mit dem
Namensschild unten drunter die werden
dann gemacht es gab heute offenbar schon
einen Probedurchlauf wie man das dann
genau handhaben will damit eben
möglichst wenig davon an die
Öffentlichkeit tritt auf der anderen
Seite hat Donald Trump aber ein großes
Interesse dass das Ganze öffentlich wird
denn er verbreitet ja eben seine Version
von
er sei das Opfer der Justiz und er werde
zu Unrecht angeklagt und deswegen hat er
ein großes Interesse daran eben zu
zeigen schaut her wie ich schlecht
behandelt werde es ist also spannend was
da am Dienstag genau passiert und weil
Donald Trump ja eben so gut ist auch im
mobilisieren seine Anhänger wie bereitet
sich New York der darauf vor was wird er
be fürchtet
naja also das ist auch eine
zweischeinheit oder zweiseitige Antwort
zum einen ist es so dass Donald Trump
eben sagt hier spendet für mich spendet
für meinen Wahlkampf spendet dafür dass
ich aus diesem Verfahren gut rauskomme
und damit verfängt er bei seinen
Anhängern bei den trampisten bei den
mager-anhängern ganz klar da hat er
mittlerweile über 2 Millionen US-Dollar
gesammelt für seinen Wahlkampf einfach
nur mit der Ankündigung ich werde
verhaftet auf der anderen Seite bereitet
sich natürlich New York vor auf mögliche
Unruhen Ausschreitungen auch da hat
Donald Trump ja gesagt es ist total
unamerikanisch was passiert mit der
Anklage und man soll sich für ihn
einsetzen wir sehen also sehr sehr viele
Polizisten in New York alle Beamte der
Stadt haben die Ansage bekommen sie
sollen ab sofort immer nur in
vollständiger Uniform aus dem Haus gehen
auch wenn sie nicht im Dienst sind
einfach um als Respekts Person
wahrgenommen zu werden man hat sehr
viele Absperrgitter aufgestellt aber
bislang ist von den erwarteten Protesten
nichts zu sehen es gibt ehrlicherweise
in New York überhaupt keine protestieren
den die sich für Trump aussprechen es
gibt einige wenige vor dem Gericht da
und hauen und es gibt einige von dem
Trump Tower die eben der sich dafür
aussprechen dass Trump jetzt angeklagt
wird es gibt nur einige wenige die sich
tatsächlich für Trump einsetzen und die
sind in Florida in Maria Lago die stehen
davor seinem Anwesen mit bunten Fahnen
wir schauen wie sich das bis Dienstag
weiter entwickelte so wohl politisch als
auch auf der anderen Ebene herzlichen
danke gut und Engel für die Analyse für
die Schilderungen
sehr gerne